Transcriber: Esin K
Gözden geçirme: Yiğit Yıldırım
Sekiz yaşında Refik Anadol, annesinin
getirdiği Blade Runner filmindeki
Los Angeles’ta mimariyi, sanatı,
işleme düşüncesi
ve bir sahne,
onu şu an olduğu Refik Anadol
haline getirmiştir.
O sahne, Android Rachael
karakterinin anılarını,
aslında kendisinin değil, başkasına ait
anılarının olduğu anlatıldığı sahne.
O sahneyi izledikten sonra, ömrünün
sonuna kadar kendisini bırakmayacak olan
‘Bir makine, başkasının anılarıyla
ne yapabilir?’ sorusuyla uğraşmıştır.
Ve cevaplayabilmek için
birçok çalışmalarda bulunmuştur.
Çalışmalarını anlatmadan önce
sanatçının kendisini,
Refik Anadol’u,
sizlerle tanıştırmak istiyorum.
Refik Anadol, 1985 İstanbul
doğumlu bir medya sanatçısı.
Alanında öncü olmakla kalmamış,
sayısız sanatçıya da ilham olmuştur.
Kurucusunun kendisi olduğu
Refik Anadol Studio’da
nörobilimciden müzisyene kadar uzanan
geniş bir gruba sahip.
Yaptığı çalışmalardan dolayı kazandığı
birçok ödülü olmakla beraber,
yükseköğrenim görmek için gittiği UCLA’da
öğretim görevlisi olarak çalışmasına,
çalışmalarına devam ediyor.
Çalışmalarını çok güzel özetlediğini
düşündüğüm bir sözü var.
Sizlerle bunu
paylaşmak istiyorum.
’Ben, veriyi pigment olarak kullanıp,
yapay zeka tarafından desteklenmiş
düşünen bir fırça ile,
mimariyi boyayarak binaların halüsinasyon
ve rüya görmesini sağlıyorum.′ diyor.
Kısıtlı süremiz olduğundan dolayı,
sadece üç tanesinden bahsedebileceğim.
Birincisi, Archive Dreaming.
İlhamını Jorge Luis Borges’in
yazmış olduğu,
Babil Kütüphanesi adlı
kısa öyküsünden almışlar.
Bu hikayede yazar,
belirli karakter setine ve fonta sahip,
yazılmış ve yazılabilecek tüm 410 sayfalık
kitapların içinde bulunacağı
bir kütüphaneden bahseder.
Bu ilham verici görüntüyle beraber
grubuyla büyük veri arşivlerini
fiziksel olarak incelemenin
yollarını aramışlar.
Bu doğrultuda SALT Araştırma Merkezi’nden
topladıkları 1 milyon 700 bin belgeyi
bir makineye taratarak uyumaya bırakmışlar
ve rüya görmesine izin vermişler.
Sonuç: Muhteşem bir deneyim.
Deneyimi, dairesel bir odanın içine
etraflanmış projektörler
ve aynalarla çevrili olarak görüyorsunuz.
Merkezdeki bilgisayarla etkileşime
geçene kadar bilgisayar,
size veriyi işlerken gördüğü rüyayı,
başından geçenleri anlatıyor.
Etkileşime geçtiğinizde de isterseniz
kullanılan 1 milyon 700 bin belgeyi,
isterseniz de makine zekasının
rüyasına tanıklık edebiliyorsunuz.
Merak edenler için de not edeyim;
yöntem, sistem, t-SNE yöntemiyle
oluşturulmuş.
Yükseköğrenim görmek için gittiği
Los Angeles’ta, gördüğü hiçbir binanın
Blade Runner filminden kalma
beklentilerini aşamadığını söylüyor,
tek bir tanesi hariç.
O da, mimar Frank Gehry’nin
büyük hayranı olduğu,
ve kendisinin bir binadan çok
heykel olarak adlandırdığı
Walt Disney Concert Hall.
Konserlerini burada veren
Los Angeles Philarmonic,
100′üncü yıllarının kutlaması için
Refik Anadol’a 2018 yılında
bir teklif göndermişler.
Grubuyla beraber teklif için
iki soruyu sormaya karar vermişler:
‘Bir bina öğrenebilir mi?’,
‘Hayal görebilir mi?’.
Bunun için, Los Angeles Philarmonic
ve Walt Disney Concert Hall arşivlerindeki
77 terabaytlık bir belgeye toparlayıp,
makine zekasını kullanarak,
Walt Disney Concert Hall’un dış
görünümüne yansımalar haline getirmişler.
Los Angeles’taki
bu gelecekçi çalışmayı
gerçekleştirmek için de
42 projektör kullanmışlar.
Ve Blade Runner’ın Los Angeles’ına
bir adım daha yaklaşılmış.
Bir bina rüya görebilecek,
hayal edebilecek olsaymış,
o bina kesinlikle bu olurdu.
Refik Anadol’un her türlü veriyi, görsel
ve işitsel malzemeye dönüştürme vizyonunun
bir diğer parçası olan Melting Memories.
İlhamını trajik bir olaydan,
amcasına Alzheimer teşhisi
konulmasından almışlar.
Grubuyla beraber neyi ve nasıl
hatırladığımıza değer vermenin yollarını
bulmak istemişler.
Bu yolculukta durakları,
ilk, Kaliforniya’daki
Neuroscape laboratuvarı olmuş.
Orada, beyin sinyallerini hatırlama ve anı
oluşturma gibi süreçlerini incelemek için
32 farklı noktadan
EEG verilerini toplamışlar.
Alfa, beta ve teta olmak üzere
üç tür sinyale
Higuchi’nin fraktal boyut algoritmasını
kullanarak ölçekleyip,
o hareketli ortamın içinde FFT kullanarak
görsel bir şölen oluşturmuşlar.
Gördüğünüz gibi Refik Anadol; yaptığı
çalışmaları detaylıca görüntülerde,
yazılarında ve açık kaynak kodlu
yazılarında paylaşmış.
Bu, Refik Anadol’un
herhangi bir sanat eserinin,
giriş ve çıkış kapısı olan müzelerde
gösterilmemesi gerektiği düşüncesinin
bir diğer parçası.
Bu süreçte amcası, hatırlama ve anı
dönüştürme gibi yeteneklerini kaybetse de,
EEG verilerinden oluşan sanat eseri,
amcasının kaybettiklerine bir övgü
olarak kalmaya devam ediyor.
Ne kadar ben sadece 3 tanesinden
bahsedebilmiş bilmiş de olsam,
ben sizin diğer çalışmalarına
göz atmanızı çok isterim.
Örnek olarak; 100 milyondan fazla New York
fotoğrafını bir makineye incelettirip,
sonra görmediği görselleri oluşturmasını
istediği Machine Hallucination,
veya Karadeniz ve Marmara
Denizi’nden topladıkları
rüzgar ve deniz hareketleri gibi
meteorolojik verilerden
oluşturmuş oldukları
Bosphorus ve Black Sea çalışmaları.
Benim size bu sunumda
vermek istediğim mesaj şudur ki:
Sanat da her alan gibi değişiyor,
dönüşüyor.
Ve bu değişimi desteklemek de bizim
diğer milli görevlerimizin arasında.
Sonuçta ulu önderimizin de dediği gibi:
’Bir millet sanattan
ve sanatkardan mahrumsa,
tam bir hayata malik olamaz.
Böyle bir millet;
ayağı topal, bir kolu çolak,
sakat, alil bir kimse gibidir.
Sanatsız kalan bir milletin hayat
damarlarından biri kopmuş olur.”
Beni dinlediğiniz için teşekkürler.
(alkış)